ya hemos hablado en varios vídeos sobre
los costos de una empresa en particular
hablamos de como el costo marginal es
impulsado por la cantidad y como el
costo total medio también es impulsado
por la cantidad además mencionamos otros
costos en este vídeo extenderemos ese
análisis presentando el concepto de
ganancia y es probable que ya estén
familiarizados con este término pero una
forma general de pensar en la ganancia
es ver cuánto recibe una empresa como
ingresos y a esa cantidad restar los
costos que tiene la empresa una empresa
razonable siempre va a querer maximizar
su ganancia para comprender cómo una
empresa puede maximizar su ganancia es
decir para encontrar la cantidad justa
que tiene que producir para maximizar la
ganancia con base en una estructura de
costos tenemos que incluir el ingreso en
este modelo en particular veremos la
idea del ingreso marginal en este
ejemplo vamos a suponer que esta empresa
está en un mercado muy competitivo por
lo que es precio aceptante es decir que
no importa cuánto produzca esta empresa
el ingreso adicional por unidad
producida
imaginemos que en este ejemplo la
empresa produce donas el ingreso
adicional por dona producida va a
permanecer igual sin importar cuánto
produzca esta empresa en particular
digamos que el ingreso marginal en este
mercado está justo aquí una forma de
pensar en esto es tomar en cuenta el
precio del mercado
aquí dibujamos el ingreso marginal
cuánto ingreso marginal tendremos por
cada unidad adicional producida pues
será el precio de esa unidad cuánto debe
producir una empresa razonable para
maximizar su ganancia si el ingreso
marginal es mayor que el costo marginal
entonces tendremos que cada unidad
adicional que se produce va a ser dinero
neto como entrada a la empresa así que
eso es lo que razonablemente la empresa
debe hacer seguir produciendo cada vez
más hasta que llegamos a este punto
interesante donde el costo marginal se
aproxima al ingreso marginal siempre y
cuando el costo marginal sea menor al
ingreso marginal es razonable que la
empresa siga produciendo más bolas pero
justo en esa unidad en donde el costo
marginal es igual al ingreso marginal en
este punto una unidad adicional
producida rompe la capacidad de producir
con ganancias aquí podría utilizar
algunos de sus costos fijos pero después
de este punto no tiene ningún sentido
que la empresa produzca más porque
porque si el costo marginal es mayor que
el ingreso marginal es como si dijéramos
que vamos a vender una dona a 10 pesos
aún cuando el costo de producir esa dona
adicional es de 12 pesos en este caso
ninguna empresa razonable que quiera
maximizar su ganancia va a hacerlo por
lo que una empresa razonable que quiera
maximizar su ganancia va a producir la
cantidad donde el costo marginal se
intersecta con el ingreso marginal es
decir va a producir esta cantidad de acá
una pregunta natural con respecto a esto
sería cuál es la ganancia que se obtiene
al producir esta cantidad para esto
tenemos que ver cuál es el ingreso
marginal en esta cantidad que también
podemos ver en este caso recordando que
el ingreso marginal es constante podemos
verlo como el ingreso medio que se
obtiene
por unidad y esto de acá es el costo
total medio por unidad así que para
calcular la ganancia lo que hacemos es
ver cuánto obtenemos en promedio por
unidad y luego multiplicar este
resultado por el número de unidades
producidas el resultado es el área de
este rectángulo para aquellos de ustedes
que sean más visuales una forma de
pensar en esto es que una empresa
razonable que quiera maximizar su
ganancia va a querer maximizar esta área
piensen en lo que pasaría si esta
empresa solamente quisiera producir esta
cantidad entonces ellos renunciarían a
esta área de acá ahora el rectángulo
tendría este tamaño menor que es la
ganancia obtenida por la empresa al
producir estas unidades si por algún
motivo no razonable esta empresa decide
producir más de esta cantidad que
dijimos aquí noten que aunque la base
del rectángulo es más grande la altura
del mismo es más pequeña por lo que el
nuevo rectángulo tendrá un área menor y
la razón por la que no tengo duda de que
este rectángulo tiene una área menor es
porque en este ejemplo la empresa está
perdiendo dinero al producir todas
unidades adicionales donde el costo
marginal es mayor que el ingreso
marginal en resumen una empresa
razonable que trata de maximizar su
ganancia producirá la cantidad de
unidades en donde el costo marginal y el
ingreso marginal sean iguales con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo